hey David is there a mass shooting
deadly enough to get Republicans to
support gun control unfortunately the
opposite might be true we are sort of
thinking about this as like okay when we
see evidence of a problem we try to
solve that problem in the way that seems
logical to us so we see all of these
countries with low gun ownership and
strict gun safety laws have no mass
shootings or almost no mass shootings
and then that makes us say wow we should
look at doing some of that stuff in the
u.s. to solve the problem of mass
shootings there's a fundamental problem
here in that the pro-gun fetishists
don't see gun control as the solution to
mass shooting so the idea of if there's
a really bad mass shooting then all of a
sudden the gun fetishists will stop
wanting more guns they'll want gun
safety no in fact the opposite is likely
to happen the worst mass shooting the
worse the mass shootings get rather the
more guns that the pro-gun fetishists
might want because they see the guns as
the solution to the mass shootings
things like gun free zones create soft
targets for mass shooters people not
having their own weapons create an
environment where a mass shooter won't
be scared that everybody might be armed
and someone might take him out before he
is able to do damage or whatever else so
I actually reject the idea that the
problem getting worse will lead to the
pro-gun right changing their mind after
Sandy Hook Obama had the presidency and
he had the house not the House and
Senate and he was not able to pass a
universal background checks even though
there was like 90% support for those in
the United States at that time that
includes a lot of right-wingers
and so this problem is far bigger it's
the culture it's the gun lobbying
organizations which exists basically to
sell guns no organization that exists to
increase the number of gun sales is ever
going to advocate for any policy that
might restrict the number of people that
can get guns or the number of guns that
can be sold there's an idea that a bunch
of people tweeted me when I said I'm
gonna be answer to this question on the
show
and they said it's urban versus rural
this is merely a question of in urban
areas where police are closer people are
less likely to believe that they are
going to need guns to protect themselves
whereas rural where police may be much
further away it is just a different
situation yes and no because remember on
the one hand Bernie Sanders has said gun
ownership in rural Vermont is different
than gun ownership in America cities and
that's true in many ways but you don't
get 90 percent agreement for a universal
100 percent on every transaction
background checks with only urban people
in the United States rural people are
also part you're not gonna get 90
percent with only people living in
cities is the point what might actually
and I hate to say this but what might
actually change things is if large
groups of minorities start to not only
armed themselves but make a big show of
it do it in the same way that a lot of
these right-wing mostly white groups do
it the open carry displays or whatever
I'm not for any of that stuff I hate it
I think it's disgusting I think it's a
waste of people's lives that that's how
they want to be activists to walk around
with guns visible in a Walmart or
wherever else on the street whatever the
case may be but I think that a lot of
the sort of hardcore conservative white
gun owners if all of a sudden gun
ownership becomes a thing of large
groups of minority gun owners publicly
displaying their firearms some of them
will defend it on principle I know but a
lot of them aren't going to like it and
it's funny because a lot of people
tweeted me David you know what'll change
things if all of a sudden armed black
militia groups armed Latino militia
groups in border states start making big
displays of their open caring where it
is legal of course and I actually think
that that might actually influence a lot
of people to start say wait hold on a
second we've got to reconsider this
although of course they would reconsider
it only in the most hypocritical way
they don't want those other people doing
it they would still want it for
themselves but it might actually shake
things up enough that you might at least
get some new conversations instead of
the talking point conversations were
stuck in now gun
mass shooting the guns aren't the
problem the fact that it was a gun-free
zone is the problem okay but what about
banning these types of weapons those
weapons are often not the ones actually
used in the crimes okay well what about
ammunition a lot of that stuff is after
money it's like the same talking point
conversations that go nowhere maybe that
would actually change that up let me
know what you think let me know what you
think would actually change the mind of
a pro-gun right-wing fetishist on this
issue